ladies and gentlemen we are very quickly
approaching a full-scale european war
between russia and ukraine in just a
period of a few hours things went from
u.s intelligence believes
large invasion is coming within the next
48 hours and then just a few hours later
uh bombings starting all over ukraine by
russia
further russian troops entering ukraine
and we are now in the middle of a
full-scale invasion of ukraine by
russian president vladimir putin there
were still people even up until minutes
before
saying this is not likely to happen it's
not likely it just doesn't seem like
it's what putin wants to do
and yet it is what's happening and we
are doing the best we can to keep up
with all of the news which is changing
very quickly let's just start somewhere
with the headline russia invades ukraine
in europe's darkest hours since world
war ii reported by reuters russian
forces invaded ukraine thursday and
understand that
it was wednesday night in the us being
seven hours later in ukraine it was
early thursday morning
in a mass assault by land sea and air
the biggest attack by one state against
another in europe since world war ii
missiles rain down
ukraine reported columns of troops
pouring across its borders from russia
and belarus and landing on the coast
from the black and azov seas
ukrainian troops fought russian forces
along practically the entire border
explosions were heard before dawn and
throughout the morning in the capital
kiev
three million people in the city gunfire
rattled sirens blared and the highway
out of the city choked with traffic as
residents fled
um
russia attacks ukraine peace in europe
shattered as reported by the associated
press
russia launched a wide-ranging attack on
ukraine thursday hitting cities and
bases with airstrikes or shelling
civilians piled into trains and cars to
flee ukraine's government said russian
tanks and troops rolled across the
border in a full-scale war
could we write the geopolitical order
and whose fallout already reverberated
around the world in unleashing moscow's
most aggressive actions since the soviet
invasion of afghanistan in 1979 that's
43 years ago putin deflected global
condemnation and cascading new sanctions
this is now starting to pull in other
european countries in the sense of
triggering nato article 4.
estonia latvia lithuania poland and
other allies are holding consultations
under nato's article 4 after russia has
attacked ukraine under article 4 of the
nato agreement the allies can hold
consultations whenever they feel the
territorial integrity political
independence or security of an ally is
threatened
this is the next signal
of what could be next and what could be
next would be
man i mean it's it's it would be
something approximating
the scope of a world war and and i
i don't want to be hyperbolic but when
we are talking about a full-scale
invasion by russia of ukraine and uh by
russia of ukraine and then we are
talking about the surrounding allies
including estonia and lithuania et
cetera getting involved
how can i not say we're talking about
something approximating a world war
i was going to report to you today
u.s warns full-scale invasion of ukraine
could be imminent this was
again in the afternoon yesterday the
story was we believe the intelligence
points in this direction it could be
coming it could be 48 hours
and then within hours it happened
within hours it happened
um
biden warns russia of further
consequences after putin's declaration
it's going to get very ugly
politically and economically
biden issued a statement wednesday night
condemning russia's president vladimir
putin's announcement of a quote special
military operation in ukraine moments
before ukrainian cities were bombarded
by russian missile strikes consider that
there were people
there were people up and i mean some
this morning are still saying it but
there were people up until last night
saying everything putin is doing is
justified because by not ruling out that
ukraine
will ever join nato
putin is justified in everything the
invasion the bomb everything
got some real real problems out there
a putin sent in troops disguised with
white peace monitor symbols and
ukrainian officials folks it's a full
invasion
troops entering the country from belarus
were reportedly disguising themselves in
ukrainian military and police
uniforms
we have various
locations of where explosions were heard
we have a map up on the screen and as
you can see it's basically the entire
country as of this morning
the western piece of ukraine which
borders romania hungary slovakia
has not yet
seen explosions but you have locations
where cnn heard explosions and then
locations where local residents reported
explosions
cnn reporting that the ukrainian
interior ministry says they have
experienced hundreds of casualties
from just the first missile strikes
hundreds already killed in ukraine the
the vibrations obviously those um
attacks
those missile strikes coming in much
closer and here's the sort of um news
that we've got from you defense
officials uh saying
that
um
this is now and this is a quote i'm
getting from the president's office at
the moment a full-blown nationwide
attack
with military infrastructure that is
being attacked nationwide so the
emphasis being on the military
infrastructure that they say
is coming under attack we've also spoken
to again
our contact at the interior ministry an
ontario ministry official saying that
across the country as a result of these
attacks
there are hundreds of casualties now we
don't know
how many of those people are dead how
many are injured or whether that figure
is accurate but we do know that the
interior ministry of ukraine is putting
the number of casualties so far in this
nationwide assault missile assault at
this stage for the most part
in the hundreds and i apologize i said
hundreds dead casualties does not uh
necessarily mean uh uh dead it means
injured or dead and we're still going to
be standing by to learn more about that
but it is it is not looking uh
particularly good the plan now is for
more sanctions more sanctions world
expresses outrage plans stronger russia
sanctions as reported by the associated
press world leaders today reacted to the
invasion with vows of unprecedented
sanctions
um and we will we will focus in more on
the sanctions
uh in another segment we have incredible
video from uh keeves central train
station just flooded with people trying
to get out of the city desperation
rising and we're showing that video to
our audience just people desperate to
get out
there are reports
of troops coming into ukraine russian
troops from all sides cnn has video of
troops crossing the border of belarus
into ukraine that's one direction from
which they are entering there are
reports of russian military forces
entering ukraine from crimea
making that
uh invasion
from eight years ago
all the more relevant today
uh this is going to be painful for
russia i mean the the russian stock
market down 40 percent
it's it's you know the if retaliation
really gets going and ukraine says there
has been some
we don't know the full scope of it yet
um it is going to be painful for russia
but it's not clear putin cares
um
ukraine's military says its air defense
did shoot down a russian plane in
eastern ukraine
ukraine is saying anyone who's ready and
able to hold a weapon can join
territorial defense forces
and understand that the russians will
want to persuade you ukraine to
surrender and not only are they
launching a multi-origin multi-platform
attack they are also likely to use
disinformation
fake video and fake photos to encourage
that ukrainian surrender and the next
several days could be some of the most
insane we have seen on this planet
geopolitically i don't even i don't even
know since when in a very very long time
and the threats are now starting to come
to the united states
russia is now threatening
american assets in response to the first
round of sanctions to the first round of
sanctions
let's start there
business insider reporting russia
threatens to target sensitive u.s assets
as part of a strong and painful response
to u.s sanctions its foreign minister
foreign affairs ministry said the
sanctions were attempt to change
russia's course
there should be no doubt that sanctions
will receive a strong response
russia's foreign affairs ministry said
the country would target sensitive
american assets in retaliation
the ministry said this is part of
america's the sanctions are part of
america's ongoing attempts to change
russia's course
russia has proved that despite all the
sanctions cost it is able to minimize
the damage
and even more so sanctions pressure is
not able to affect our determination to
firmly defend our interests it added
there should be no doubt that sanctions
will receive a strong response not
necessarily symmetrical but finely tuned
and painful to the american side the
united states on the other hand plans to
continue escalating the sanctions i
don't even pretend to know where this
will end but it is very clear
that all along you know we had we had
reports which said
here's what we know
here's what could happen
and then here's a less bad
scenario just about every element of
this so far
has been closer to the worst case
scenario now obviously there were people
talking about nuclear war
uh as a worst case scenario i don't
believe that will happen i don't believe
we're going in that direction uh i think
that that that's that's quite literally
it would be a suicide decision uh by
putin and russia but from from the sort
of more reasonable
could this be trying to take a little
bit of territory could this escalate
into bombing keeve it's all going in the
worst direction
uh and economically it's also already
doing significant significant damage um
understand also by the way that
russia has changed its tune on the
sanctions pretty quickly i mean two days
ago russia was saying we don't care
about sanctions they're not really going
to do anything
now russia is saying
the sanctions are
painful and we are going to retaliate
specifically for the sanctions so it
should not be lost on us that russia has
changed its opinion of the sanctions as
stated so that's the latest that we know
at this point within two hours things
may have changed we will of course be
live later with the latest
and you can find me on twitter at
dpakman and let me know your latest
thoughts on what's taking place
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support to fund what we do the best way
to do it the most direct way to support
our work is to get a membership on our
website joinpacman.com
you can use the coupon code wow 22 for a
discount if you so please
uh we also have uh a great david pakman
show subreddit where nearly 35 000 of
our viewers are engaging in polite
respectful non-trolling discussion of
political issues you can join the
discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit many interesting posts i spotted
including
some people apologizing for having
fallen for tulsi gabbard here's one post
from a user who says as a veteran of two
foreign wars i took the bait for her
scam
hook line and sinker i'm anti-war and i
supported that message i'm guilty of
falling for it and want to apologize to
sir
pacman well i i have not been knighted
so no reason to say sir um yeah i mean
listen you don't have to apologize to me
it just i think it would be great at
this point that tulsi has gone full mask
off
defending defending russia over the last
couple days and just crazy crazy uh
check out my twitter for some of her
recent wacky statements it's just great
to realize if you were duped you were
duped and no you are susceptible to
being duped and that will hopefully
protect you better in the future that i
think is is what you know i don't need
an apology it's just let's all recognize
how did it happen and how can i prevent
myself
inoculate myself from being duped again
another user
says get you someone who speaks to you
the way david speaks to the people from
europe i love when we get calls from
europe i find it interesting i find it
interesting that we have people in other
countries that pay attention to the show
and if it's a part of europe i've been
to i love reminiscing about when i used
to travel to europe
which has not has not happened for some
time other than
the spain trip which sort of went
horribly wrong a few months ago but we
don't really talk about that anymore
um but we love our callers from the
united states as well of course uh they
make up the majority of our audience
lastly another user on the subreddit
points out why do i get so many right
wing shorts on youtube almost everyone
i'm subscribed to is liberal but almost
all my shorts are right wing not saying
i just want to be in a left-wing bubble
but it's kind of weird
this is not so here's what's going on
with youtube shorts
it's mostly right-wingers producing
youtube shorts youtube shorts is a new
short form vertical video format similar
to instagram reels similar to tick tocks
and
it is mostly being used on youtube by
the right wing so we started producing
shorts
a couple months ago and we are
continuing to build and i encourage
every other left-wing show start
producing and publishing shorts we can't
let the right control the format and the
reason you're getting so many right-wing
shorts is it's mostly right-wingers
producing them and we're now doing one
or two a day
and we're going to keep going with it we
we can't seed these platforms to the
right
join the discussion on the david pakman
show subreddit davidpakman.com
reddit all right i want to talk about
what i guess we're calling the alt left
on the topic of ukraine and russia i got
a question during a live stream recently
which was basically how did i and a
streamer named hassan [ __ ] end up with
such different opinions of the russian
invasion of ukraine now i don't have the
answer to that specific question but i
want to more generally address that
there is a contingent
of people who claim to be on the left
and that includes folks like glenn
greenwald matt tybee and tulsi gabbard
and others who have a very different
perspective on ukraine russia
from what i would call kind of the
mainline progressive left of which i am
a part now some of you will say david
your entire premise is flawed those
people aren't really on the left i grant
you
there's a real question as to whether
these people are actually on the left i
mean they're they're extremely
reactionary in much of what they say but
let's put that aside for now because
they're ostensibly on the left they sort
of claim to be and are considered by
many to be on the left let's call it the
alt left and you decide whether they are
on the left or are not and for our
purposes we'll be open to the idea that
they are on the left also i think it's
important to mention
some some are like why aren't you just
talking about tankies the so-called
revolutionary left this is a different
group the alt left like tulsi is not
what would pejoratively be described as
a tanki
she's something else and so that's why
we're looking for a different name and
we're calling it the alt-left i believe
there is often
one real story
and sometimes terms like bias
alternative facts and narrative
are used to create doubt about whether
you've been misled or sold a fake story
and that there's a true real story that
you're not getting
and there's the usual suspects that are
blamed now sometimes there really are
competing narratives with elements of
truth and we have to be
very very involved in sort of
ascertaining what the truth is on russia
i believe there is one story
and that that story can be detailed and
contain nuance and that's fine
vladimir putin's decision to invade
ukraine is the principal aggression in
this scenario putin has had territorial
ambitions for reasons of ego economics
and geopolitics for decades he hasn't
made those territorial ambitions a
secret he uh is obsessed with ukraine
for reasons we outlined on the monday
bonus show including this sort of vague
nostalgia for the ussr as well as
resource and economy and geography
related reasons he's now acting on them
period russia invaded ukraine russia
isn't respecting ukraine's border
sovereignty and putin is now pushing
into kiev with the bombings that started
overnight applied anywhere else
no one would accept the idea that
listen it's legitimate to recognize the
separatists in another country as
independent and then send in tanks to
protect them and then start bombing kiev
and it's not an invasion we wouldn't
accept that in almost any other scenario
in addition okay
in addition
the situation is more complicated
because it is true
that russia might in a real way in a
genuine way
see nato's willingness to defend ukraine
and nato nato's eastward expansion as a
sign of aggression i'm not denying that
russia could very well see it that way
it doesn't change
that russia invaded ukraine
is shelling all over the country sending
troops in through belarus crimea etc and
not respecting the simple border
sovereignty of ukraine
that um they are supposed to respect
great
but the alt-left doesn't agree with that
now i'm going to do my best to
accurately represent different
perspectives from the alt-left but they
include for example that the entire
government intelligence and media
apparatus is lying about what happened
this is a very common theme from the
alt-left and again the alt-left has
hammers and so everything looks like
nails to the left you can't trust the
media generically even though the media
means a hundred different things you
can't trust intelligence because
sometimes intelligence has been wrong
you can't trust world leaders about
what's going on and this often includes
more specific counter stories like this
is actually joe biden's fault
nato is to blame as an imperialist force
that is overreached putin is just
defending his country stuff like that
they said the threat from putin is
overblown he has no real interest in
invading he doesn't plan to it's a lie
you've been sold by the fear-mongering
bloodthirsty government intel media
apparatus for attention posturing the
military-industrial complex and clicks
but no invasion is coming
we know that was wrong
these are very clearly bogus takes not
based in evidence and we now have the
benefit of hindsight to see how wrong
they were
the biden administration
did something smart
counter to what happened in 2014 with
crimea
biden came out and said for a while
our intelligence shows a buildup of
troops on the border which signals maybe
putin wants to invade
and then biden said our intelligence is
that putin has made the decision to
invade
and then
yesterday they said we have intelligence
that there will be a full-scale invasion
within 48 hours it all happened
it all happened and then
biden was on record saying this is the
plan
and that allows us to say hey you know
what we were getting two different
stories and one was correct and the alt
left was very very wrong
all along the biden administration was
detailing exactly what was happening in
the expected timeline and it came true
now another alt-left trope is biden
wants war
biden did this
he warned us
as part of sabre rattling to gin up
support for a war
and everybody other than the alt-left
wants that war
first of all no we don't
i mean
find
one clip of me saying anything
even indirectly alluding to the vague
desire for any kind of war no
we don't want war secondly biden has
said
no troops on the ground
and he's sticking to it now if he
changes his mind i'll tell you
but people like matt taebe and glenn
greenwald and tulsi have talked and
alluded to this desire for war that
biden and the media and everybody but
them have
which uh people like them are again so
like matt taibbi tweeted i have a long
record of being critical of putin this
troll fantasy that i'm pro-putin comes
from reporting correctly that russia
gate was fake and deposing u.s
intervention of ukraine that doesn't
make me pro-putin any more than opposing
the iraq war made me a saddam lover he
insists he's just against ukrainian
intervention everybody else wants it
well biden also by the definition that
we're talking about sending troops is
against intervention and is sticking to
it now of course i am the first to tell
you
we are increasingly engaged in a proxy
war along along with our allies
i just want to tell you what things are
i have no interest in hiding that from
you we're arming ukraine
uh we're sanctioning
yeah it's increasingly a proxy war
against russia fine but the idea of this
bloodthirsty ground war that put that
biden is determined to launch no tulsi
similarly pretending you know there's
some kind of bloodlust from biden and
harris tweeting biden harris tell us we
must bear the cost to defend freedom in
ukraine but while you and your family
struggle with higher gas prices the
power elite won't suffer at all and if
the conflict goes nuclear nuclear there
they'll be safe and cushy massive
bunkers while you and your loved ones
fry no she was wrong about all of it i
mean it's harder to find alex berenson
was like the wrongest man in the world
on the pandemic
tulsi has been like the wrongest
american on russia ukraine and then
here's glenn greenwald who tweeted
whenever war emerges there is an intense
surge of nationalism in the u.s people
across the spectrum unified the media
speaks in almost lockstep so i'm sure
the polls will indicate approval for now
but i really wonder how much americans
are willing to sacrifice for ukraine
again no one's talking about that
certainly not biden certainly not
mainline progressive leftists like me it
was a lie so the alt-left is very
misguided they got a big boost in 2016.
that's when the alt left really started
to get built up the origins of the
alt-left
are heavily based in the idea that trump
is uniquely the fault of the left there
are these folks who started saying in
2016 hillary's just as bad as trump uh
then trump won and they said it's the
fault of the left for their narrative
and their selection of people like
hillary they insisted the trump-russia
stuff was all made up and that trump's
wrongdoing wasn't important they never
blamed
the outrageous ignorant reactionary
extremist right-wingers who actually
voted for trump they blamed the left but
not those right-wingers
and this has carried them through now to
their takes on ukraine russia so that's
what's going on
they're wrong
i'm bored by them if you want you know
and i say this because there's so many
people telling me i should have those
views just go watch those other shows
read those other people it's not what we
do here
it this just isn't an alt-left show so
rather than wasting time emailing me
telling me i should adopt glenn
greenwald and tulsi's views just go
listen you don't have to watch this show
it's optional it's a free country as as
so many people like like to say
just tune me out if that's what you're
uh looking for
um we'll have more coverage of this on
our instagram which you can find at
david pakman's show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show on uh what is quickly becoming an
historic day or a historic day depending
on your grammatical preference uh it's
great to be joined by bill share who's a
contributor to the washington monthly
real clear politics politico
bill you know i
let's
not immediately include the ukraine
russia situation in our conversation and
sort of start with like if this weren't
going on
what would your thoughts have been
on
where the 2022 midterms seem to be
looking in terms of
who's going to control the house and
senate um after november and and then
maybe we'll integrate the question about
russia ukraine
um
well
you know in one respect you would say
things don't look good for democrats
obviously
any time the president's party is facing
a midterm it tends to not go great
we've had
36
midterms since the civil war and the
president's party loses house seats in
33 of those 36.
uh
now of course a lot of those times they
don't lose control of congress because
the margins are bigger but now the
margin is five so even the slightest
loss u.s losing control
uh and if biden's at the same job
approval in november as he is today
which is about 42
that's not going to be
a good midterm
having said that there there are those
three exceptions
and there's also a fourth exception
where the democrat where democrats lost
less than five seats that was 1962. so
those four exceptions are 1934
1962 1998 2002. so what's what's the
thread in those exceptions
uh 34 is fdr's first term he's tackling
the great depression 62 cuban missile
crisis is solved 10 days before the
midterm 1998 republicans are
moving towards impeaching bill clinton
and there's a lot of talk in the air of
constitutional crisis and 2002 we're
still in the shadow of of 9 11.
crisis is the is the threat of those
four exceptions if you're in the
president's party and there's a crisis
and you're seen as handling that crisis
well right you can beat those odds right
now as it stands today we have again not
counting ukraine um two big crises that
are intertwined the pandemic in
inflation
today
biden is not seen as handling those well
so that's not becoming a plus it is
certainly possible that by november the
pandemic's going to look a lot better
and inflation's going to look a lot
better
we can't say for certain today i mean
omicron's definitely already winding
down and we just don't know if another
new variant's going to kick up between
now and then it's going to throw us for
another loop um
but and ukraine is a third crisis and
again i'm not it's hardly
uh one cannot glibly say obayan's going
to take care of this fantastically it's
a very very complicated problem and even
the most fantastic president might
handle it in the most perfect of ways um
but to add to that bill i mean no matter
what biden does republicans will blame
him i mean they're already doing it last
night trump with laura ingram saying the
problem here is biden and the rigged
election and people coming over the u.s
mexico border that he said that's the
cause of what's happening in russia
ukraine uh you have a bunch of people
already saying he it's his fault and to
some degree that may stick at least in
some voters minds well
let's not completely assume
that it's going to be
the unanimous republican message that
biden is
a weak leader and this is all this fault
sort of investors out there pushed by
trump
uh
uh
i'm not even going to argue that there's
a better than even odds the republicans
won't do that they very well could
but there is division
in the republican party on a number of
fronts and certainly ukraine is one of
those those issues and and policy versus
russia is one of those issues um
one thing i think
could help biden and democrats you know
both of ukraine and beyond
is to play up
bipartisanship
the reason why
the president's party usually does
poorly in midterms is you get a pendulum
swing
because the governing party has to
govern
governing is difficult
you have to make compromises you have to
you can't deliver on everything that
your base wants to see in the platform
unexpected crises occur
all these things put stress
on a diverse governing coalition and the
opposition can put aside their
differences and just focus on how much
they hate you that's the normal order of
midterm business but we already have
um
secured some bipartisan victories the
biggest one being the infrastructure
bill uh there are some smaller ones
along with that uh and this is done with
the help of mitch mcconnell
which has made donald trump very mad
donald trump actively attacks mitch
mcconnell for helping biden yeah uh and
we've seen biden give conflicting
messages on the score sometimes he wants
to say oh we would do a lot better these
republicans weren't obstructing us and
sometimes he says we're making
washington work and getting things done
and i would lean more towards that
latter message than the former because
one it shows you are getting things done
electing us has been good for you we've
done some good things if things aren't
perfect in the universe um
and
it drives wages through the opposition
so you want you want to be unified
yourself and divide the other guys right
and if binding can do things with
ukraine
that pull in
the more hawkish anti-putin types in the
republican party the lindsey grahams the
marco rubios the mitch mcconnells
uh
if it can make it uncomfortable for them
to side with trump that's going to
further help reverse the normal
trajectory of a midterm
i i can't help but think that if the
last four days
were not what they have been with
ukraine russia
there would be many discussions like the
ones my audience was having prior to
that point like for example
if biden can only forgive some student
loans between now and november if biden
can decriminalize cannabis federally
between now and over these types of
things which it quite frankly doesn't
seem biden has any interest at all in
doing many in my audience feel very
strongly that that would have a
significant impact on the outcome of the
midterms
what do you think about that well i mean
you gotta do two things i mean unifying
the party and splitting the opposition
requires two things you gotta do
something to energize your own base yes
and you gotta
don't take your eye off the swing the
swing still exists um doing both those
things is complicated uh and there's
inherent tensions there uh i don't know
if do what things you suggest which are
executive order things
which may go beyond what bayern thinks
is actually constitutional or legal and
would be admitting price subject to
litigation
uh
that might not be in biden's comfort
zone i do think it would be greatly
helpful to get some significant piece of
what was called buildback better passed
um to let that progressive base know hey
this was this wasn't a waste of your
time getting us elected we've done some
things that are significant significance
here right now the progressive base is
feeling that they've gotten the short
end of the stick and i understand that
and i do think you got to give them
something and then so i see folks more
inclined to think about what can buy do
what can biden do by himself because i
don't trust joe manchin or chris
cinnamon to do anything helpful um
but
whatever it is
i think it needs to be something that
can get done and will stick yes um so
that progressive base feels like they
got something out of this part of why as
you laid out
uh it's not looking great for democrats
in november are these historical
realities that you laid out very clearly
regarding the 36 midterms since the
civil war the other part of it that i am
very strongly paying attention to
is that it doesn't really seem democrats
are doing anything particularly helpful
to themselves in many ways and so i'm
sort of looking for help from
republicans in hurting themselves and
one of the things i'm looking at that i
think is probably okay for democrats is
this sort of civil war aspect of what's
going on in the republican party you've
got it used to be just pro and
anti-trump but now you've got the never
trump the pro-trump and the formerly
pro-trump which are increasingly sort of
making some noise it seems to me absent
any great strategy from democrats i
welcome that sort of infighting and it
sounds like you're saying in general
division on the opposite side is a good
thing
oh absolutely and there's certainly
things that could happen
with trump's
very aggressive involvement in
republican primaries right that's going
to be hurtful to republicans and we
can't know you know it's possible trump
backs a lunatic and that lunatic wins
the primary and wins general election
which is of course not good i mean but
we have examples in very recent past
where republicans have nominated people
that threw away winnable seats you know
christine o'donnell in delaware um
uh todd aiken in missouri richard
murdoch in indiana um you know this is
all pre-trump
and trump's not getting very involved in
all sorts of races senate and house and
governor uh you know one of the big you
know difficult races for democrats is
going to be georgia where rafael warnock
is uh holding on to
a seat very tenuously
uh and you got trump
pushing herschel walker who's got a
whole litany of scandals in his past
and
encouraging a bloodiest political civil
war between brian kemp and david perdue
uh so and if there's a there's a book
coming out called flip by greg bluestein
it's not quite out yet i just i just it
hasn't been published yet but i just
wrote a book review of it so i'm it's on
my mind i mean the things that
republicans did in georgia in the run-up
to 2020 are just comically ridiculous
and self-defeating um uh and you know
democrats did a lot of things right
republicans did a lot of things wrong
and democrats just barely won those
races so it's very possible that trump's
going to lead republicans on a very bad
path
uh and throw away
opportunities for them
at this point the specifically the
discussions of the election was stolen
who does that help and hurt in your
calculation
i mean look at the look at georgia it
that hurt republicans in georgia in 2020
for the runoffs yeah we know that
turnout went down in very red
conservative rural areas particularly in
the place where trump held rallies
between the november election the
january runoff uh so i i don't know that
will replicate
uh in 2022 but that is a risk for
republicans as if if if trump poisons
the well and tells folks that things are
still rigged that can hurt them now
another issue with 2022 is who's going
to win the secretary of state primaries
how many secretary of state races are
these issues going to be front and
center and how does that impact uh
turnout are they going to get pushed
above the fold that be more prominent uh
you know do they unify
the trumpian right and energize their
base or do they alienate those i mean
like like in georgia there was white
college educated romney-type voters that
were appalled right what trump was doing
and they moved to the democrats
so there is at risk for republicans
there as well
in terms of some of the factions on the
left you know for a while there's been
pejoratively they're called tankies i
think a less pejorative term is the
revolutionary left
and you know they're kind of like uh
nicholas maduro's good and cool and
castro cuba it's cool and they were sort
of like pro putin but there's now this
other faction that i called the alt left
like for example glenn greenwald
and tulsi gabbard they're not
revolutionary left but they certainly
seem to be this alt-left thing they were
saying putin's not going to invade all
this stuff
are these factions
how sizable do you think these factions
are in terms of the people that actually
vote beca and the reason i ask it that
way is in the 2020 democratic primary
if you looked on reddit and twitter you
would have dramatically overestimated
the level of support for someone like
bernie but when it came to voting in the
primary that was not where the
democratic party was at the time so like
how big do you think these factions are
well i mean i think the bernie faction
is a whole lot bigger than the tulsi
factory oh absolutely without a doubt
i mean i think greenwald has really
discredited himself amongst much of the
left like he's really what he's held on
to is you know tulsi left which is which
is a splinter yeah you know he's mostly
celebrated on the right these days
uh than the left so i mean there is this
sort of horseshoe you know dynamic where
they're people to have this kind of mix
of mixed positions and uh they're
generally
you know anti-deep state anti-american
establishment anti-multi-industrial
complex establishment they lump a lot of
things into that that rubric um to the
point where they go as far as say as
greenwald apparently is arguing that
this isn't really an invasion
um that america brought this on because
i mean there's a there's a jackman
article saying well uh that's a little
not as common to putin as some others
but saying well it's not it's not all
putin's fault because we wouldn't do the
compromise
where you we say ukraine can't be a nato
uh and
i understand there's certainly times in
life where you do some strategic
ambiguity to avoid to avoid conflict but
it's pretty clear that ukraine has a
good reason to want to be in nato
because britain is hell bent on on
occupying them they want that protection
so they don't get obliterated uh and so
it's hard for me to
take that off the equate out of the
equation when looking at the situation
uh so i mean that those voices are out
there they're certainly
easy to hear in social media because
they're loud right but as far as their
impact electorally i think it's very
small yeah and it seems the effect is
more getting those people to stay home
because they it's sort of like in the
2016 the alt left in 2016 often seem to
argue it's kind of irrelevant whether
it's trump or hillary and to me it
seemed less about it turned votes from
hillary to trump than it just made some
people stay home who probably would have
voted for hillary
yeah and and we didn't have that in 2020
i mean people were angry enough for
trump without whatever
their idiosyncratic foreign policy views
were
or whatever their concerns about how
moderate biden would be
that became secondary to stopping trump
i mean right the classic exam you you
put aside your differences you unify
around the common enemy uh and
uh look
dealing with ukraine
it's not going to be
necessarily easy to unite a broad swath
of america around whatever policy we
adopt because it's particularly if we're
doing something that is um somewhat
aggressive and you know no one's talking
about you know troops on the ground of
course but even even economic sanctions
could
get blow back where russia does economic
things to us or cyber attacks on us and
creates disruption and discomfort within
america
it's not a given that the average
american is going to appreciate that and
and
and
believe that this is worth the sacrifice
that we're doing it's going to take
rhetorical effort on the part of this is
where
bipartisan would help
you know as much as you and i might
really think marco rubio is appalling
lindsey graham was appalling just as a
matter of politics
if biotin is saying
we gotta take these
these actions to check putin and it's
gonna mean some hurt at the pump it's
gonna mean some uh complications with
our cyber infrastructure we're gonna do
our best to counter it uh but you gotta
expect it's gonna be hard sometimes
if a rubio and a gram and a cow giving
biting cover and saying he's doing the
right thing
that's gonna mitigate the ability for
those on like you know alt left types
uh who are gonna or carlson types are
gonna try to push into the media
bloodstream
why are we doing this
biden is making you pay five dollars the
pump for what ukraine why should you
care about that um people on the fringes
are going to push that argument and it's
an argument that can have some traction
yeah um so so in that respect they're
relevant players
uh you know if they're not necessarily
electorally large
uh and the more
diverse cover biden has whatever actions
he takes the better he's gonna be able
to withstand that and try to get the
american people on its side
well the next five days both in terms of
what happens in ukraine russia and then
up to and including what biden chooses
to say at a state of the union address
are definitely going to be uh
worth worth following we've been
speaking with bill share contributor to
the washington monthly real clear
politics politico bill always great
having you on
great to talk to you take care
follow the david pakman show on social
media interact with me and other david
pakman show viewers you'll be able to
see when we're taking calls live on the
show we post hilarious video clips
you'll see exclusive show content not on
the show and you'll be the first to see
big announcements like upcoming guests
and more follow me on twitter at dpakman
and davidpakmanshow we're on instagram
david.pakman join the reddit community
at davidpakman.com
reddit and you can also find the david
pakman show on facebook
discord and tick tock it's almost too
easy
the deranged hellscape that is the
modern american right wing just
continues to get worse i want to look at
a couple of data points for you guys
last night quite literally as vladimir
putin and russia started bombing in
ukraine sending missiles to kiev and
kharkiv and all over the country quite
literally
donald trump again praised vladimir
putin this time at a very strange speech
he gave at his own mar-a-lago resort now
yesterday i brought you the clip
of donald trump saying um on this
podcast hosted by buck sexton and
another guy
uh trump saying that putin was savvy
and smart and genius for what he did to
ukraine and some people said david that
was taken out of context
well trump doubled down on it again
here is donald trump at a mar-a-lago
event last night saying putin is smart
he's taken a country over for two
dollars worth of sanctions i'd say
that's pretty smart take a look at this
trump said he's smart i mean he's taken
over a country
for two dollars worth of sanctions i'd
say that's pretty smart trump is saying
yeah it is smart it is smart trump's
actually responding to the people who
said wow to buck sexton trump said how
smart putin is that's crazy and trump is
going it is smart what putin's doing is
smart now i understand in this clip he's
not saying
i support it but he's clearly enamored
with the authoritarian nature of putin
as we've known for years
he's taking over a country a
really a vast
vast
location a great
piece of land with a lot of people it's
just great real estate that putin's
getting for two bucks of sanctions
this would have never happened ever in a
million years would have never happened
and i know him very well i know
probably almost as well as i know
anybody
well if trump really has the
relationship with putin that he claims
to have and if this really would never
have happened uh if trump was currently
in power
why doesn't trump just call putin and
say hey it's time to lay off ukraine i
mean if trump wants us to believe that
putin respects trump
[Laughter]
trump wants us to believe that putin
listens to trump
and that trump has power over over putin
well
if you don't like what he's doing just
call him and say hey it's time to lay
off and of course the answer is either
because trump doesn't have that
relationship with putin or because he
likes what vladimir putin is doing now
he's certainly impressed with it i don't
think trump cares at all about ukraine
i think trump is probably indifferent
about putin invading ukraine trump
doesn't care about ukrainians or ukraine
uh but he can't just say i love the
invasion instead he has to just talk
about how smart vladimir vladimir putin
is
imagine for a second by the way
if trump
was president when this was going on it
would be like another rehash of when
trump met with putin in helsinki and
asked him about the hacking where he's
like oh putin denied it very strongly i
just spoke to putin and he says the
invasion is fine i asked him
did you do anything wrong and he said
sir no everything we're doing in ukraine
is okay and he said it very strongly it
was a very putin was very strong on it
so i believe him the invasion's fine
that's what would be going on and uh if
you think this is bonkers just wait
until we look at these next series of
clips last night
as the missiles were raining down in
ukraine from russia kiev all over the
country as russian troops were pouring
in from belarus and in from crimea and
over into the dunets and luhans because
all of this is happening
trump
goes on fox news
is interviewed by laura ingraham
and says
this all happened because of the rigged
of the rigged election
um
i mean guys
let's just listen
look probably ever we were energy
independent and he blew we're just we're
just learning that u.s officials are
looking at um a potential amphibious
landing now
in odessa ukraine again
a month ago or three weeks ago all the
so-called experts were saying that you
know putin was probably going to just be
content with staying in those separatist
regions
uh but i think given what's unfolded
sadly with a lot of weakness in the
united states
they just decided to go for it right so
laura tees it up and says putin probably
so like they were so wrong about the
intelligence these people
we had all the intel and it's like it
really looks like they're planning an
invasion they're like no no no no and
now they're saying well
we were wrong but because we didn't
think the u.s would be so weak to cause
the invasion and trump just teased it
you know she teased it up and trump hits
it out of the park as far as they're
concerned
it looks like they're going for it and
where does that leak nato the nato
alliance i think you're exactly right i
think that's what happened he was going
to be satisfied with the beast and now
he sees the weakness and the
incompetence and the stupidity of this
administration and as an american i'm
angry about it and i'm saddened by it
and it all happened because of a rigged
election this would have never happened
that includes
inflation and that includes millions of
people pouring in on a monthly basis far
more than 3 million people and they're
coming from 129 different countries wait
a second so
putin's invading russia
because you falsely believe the election
was stolen from you and undocumented
immigrants from latin america are coming
to the united states this is a bizarre
foreign policy analysis we have no idea
what's happening and they're destroying
our country president trump we actually
have just hold on i'm so sorry to
interrupt you but we have uh we're going
to the yeah they're going to something
so moments later this is this is just
incredible moments later
trump seems to think that laura ingram
told him that the u.s has launched an
attack on ukraine and trump's like you
shouldn't have said that and laura
ingram has to say no no no the russians
launched an amphibious attack on ukraine
guys trump seems to think that the story
is the us invaded the invaded ukraine
i
monitor this continue to monitor
statements um we'll go back to president
trump for a quick reaction uh we had a
kind of a really pathetic display from
the ukrainian president zielinski
earlier today president trump where he
in russian he doesn't like to speak
russian but in russian he was
essentially imploring vladimir putin not
to invade his country
and now we basically have the ukrainian
uh ambassador to the united nation
nations
looking like a defeated man all right
you guys ready for this listen to this
uh your final reaction
well i think the whole thing again would
have never happened it shouldn't happen
and it's a very sad thing but you know
what's also very dangerous is you told
me about the amphibious attacks
by americans you shouldn't be saying
that because you and everybody else
shouldn't know about it they should do
that secretly not be doing that through
the great laura ingraham they should be
doing that secretly nobody should know
that laura and you know
that was the russian
now those are the russian the russian
thought
uh
amphibious
that i thought you said that you were
sending people no no no the u.s
officials
she said u.s officials
you know
are seeing that there's an amphibious
attack happening imagine being so dazed
and clueless
that in the midst of russia invading
ukraine
and the u.s clearly being on the side
that russia is in the wrong as a former
president you believe that what's
happening is the u.s has launched an
amphibious attack and invasion of
ukraine
it guys we're screwed
we're screwed um here's one last very
strange uh
segment from this interview if uh any
western nation or any nation intervenes
with this russian military action
well this is something that should have
never happened this would not have
happened during my administration in
fact some people were saying why didn't
this state take place uh over the last
four years
during our administration and it didn't
for a very good reason and i'll explain
that to you someday
but
very soon the evidence is going to come
forward about why this invasion
does not take place one day
trump will explain why it didn't take
place under his watch unhinged
unhint global laughingstock
the level of aggression
of putin
is matched only by the level of
ignorance
of donald trump at the same time as this
invasion is going on
we have a voicemail number and that
number is
to david p earlier in the week said i'm
no longer going to be apologizing and
explaining things to the five percent of
my audience that needs things to be
explained and and disclaimed uh here's a
caller who says david i hate to break it
to you it's not five percent of your
audience twenty percent of your audience
is is that dumb i disagree but here's
the caller
do you think
that it's only five percent of your
audience who requires your what you
consider to be
over explaining david
number one you're not really over
explaining
uh not by a long shot you know what's
funny
this guy is in that five percent the
this is a caller
who has a call after i say things like
i'm not for
aggression and boots on the ground you
know i i give all the disclaimers
this is a guy who has called in
completely ignoring everything i said
whatever his opinion is he's in the
group whether it's the five or twenty
percent number two i think is way more
than five percent maybe it could be as
high as
20
that's a gut feeling i have based on
life experience
and all other things that need to go
into that mix your education experiences
uh i said life experience yeah um
listen whether it's five or twenty
percent this guy is in that group
because i've had to explain things
multiple times because he calls in all
angry
uh attributing the the worst possible
faith
interpretation of what i said so okay
anyway it's maybe five percent maybe ten
we'll look into that we have a great
bonus show for you today unfortunately
and this is really unfortunate as
predicted
what's going on in russia ukraine
is giving china some ideas
and taiwan has now raised its alert
level
uh we're going to talk about that
also justin trudeau has ended his use of
the emergencies act related to the
canadian trucker convoy saying it's no
longer necessary there were people
saying this is the beginning of a
permanent emergencies act there was no
evidence of that and trudeau has already
ended it and lastly the the
international space station program is
ending and we're going to talk about
what comes next
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show i would love for you to sign
up and get instant access
sign up at join pacman.com